did you watch the UFC I did man did you
know I didn't want to watch cowboy lose
oh come on you're just busy and forget
to watch it you always watch Joey yeah I
just want to watch him good yeah I
didn't thought I was gonna win I didn't
you didn't no no no really
mm-hmm just a rough fight for him what
do what explain stylistically and then
also cowboy whenever he's fighting a guy
that he's friendly with he never
performs at his highest level he needs
that adversity so he's friendly with
that Justin they should be trained
predators long oh [ __ ] I think camp
stuff like that oh just a knife is it
suck to see why why is Joe just engaging
the rumor is even get Connor Nick
because Justin though is such a push
forward kind of fight all pressure
Donald's slow started Gaetti the fast
star in the UFC
oh comes at you like a [ __ ] because I
just feel like Diane Donald one song
gets your rhythm then he starts piecing
you up smooth give you a check it his
rhythm this goes well awful matchup for
did Glover win yeah what's the best Todd
Duffee Todd Duffee back he won nope
I poked in the eye all right mmm that's
a bummer yeah um she Tyson Fury I don't
know did you ride a haul win yeah I
didn't go through it did you ride a haul
win yep that's what it says right yeah
hmm uh fury one though he had the
biggest cut on his I saw that cut he's
about to lose it's crazy if they would
stop the fights out ahead but no left
hook
that's why Fury's the corner thought it
was a headbutt and they're like oh cool
if they stop it will go to the judges
scorecards or it'd be a drawl uh you're
no contest but as a left hook oh my god
this sweet blast him with a left hook ah
is filthy fancy guy was not white I was
it was there was there uh I mean that
looks like a shark bite looks like the
[ __ ] head what what what happened
with um it was the guy giving it to him
was it a very close fight the first five
rounds was five six rounds were you know
the Swede was definitely when maybe half
of them but then fury took over Jews but
that's why I fight though that's why you
Vaseline your face right that's why the
amount of Vaseline they put on his face
was insane yeah but thank God to the
bond they close that and if I like that
how don't close it and when when did
that happen what route fourth round
Oh different yeah what can you fought
the distance here's for throwing out
sounds right
ed in it and then between rounds you
know the bell ding ding are like night
the tenth round the sweet takes his
glove and rub the side to try me yeah
terrible what
really that's an obnoxious great fight
though
watch that the cut made it that just way
more exciting oh I think I was out there
that been a boy yeah it was super
excited I got just because you're
worried yeah you stop over and then the
entire boxing world
[ __ ] hmm I didn't know that I thought it
was just a I thought it was like a
contest or huh but men thank God when
does ruler ground when does Ruiz Joshua
I'm excited about and then Wilder starts
in a third that happened the third round
Wilder verse Ortiz is in November
well that's gonna be exciting although
before was just dangerous fight man
isn't it Ortiz is so much older though
idea might be 65 may 22 what about when
it's spent porter 28 September 20 a.m. I
can't I do
it's nowhere just not happen tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]